on the edge of its hume in a forest the
grim reality of war
nestled between the trees graves of
those who died during the russian
occupation of the city
each has a story at the moment unknown
ukraine says some of the bodies exhumed
show signs of torture
we are here at a place where you can see
three graves in the first one there's a
rope on the neck and the hands are tied
on some bodies we see traces of torture
the burial site was discovered after the
russians left a few days ago police say
they are mostly civilians but bodies of
17 ukrainian soldiers were pulled out of
a mass grave on the edge of the burial
site
investigators and forensic experts are
already at work there are hundreds of
graves here in the forest some of them
are marked and appear to even have the
date of death but there are many others
that are just numbered
sergey came to identify some of them
46 of his neighbors died in the
airstrike that targeted his building
he pulled their bodies out of the rubble
people had to pay for the burial and if
you didn't have money then they were
buried with a number
sometimes they put signs like woman with
a red coat those who were burying were
maybe local fixers russians and
separatists from donetsk and luhansk
russia invaded itsum in the early days
of the war
it was used as a logistical hub to
supply its forces in the donbas
it's now a city in ruins desolate
there's no power water or gas
ukrainian soldiers are back on the
streets but tatiana wonders how she's
going to face the approaching winter she
says some people froze to death alone in
their homes at the beginning of the war
sitting on the bench nearby olga says
most of the death happened
i can say it's a mass grave people bury
their dead anywhere they could in their
gardens and squares the russian mayor
then send a team to exhume the bodies
from around the city and took them near
the cemetery she's hoping to find her
husband who also died in an airstrike
natalia also tells me she doesn't know
where her father is buried at 80 he died
of fear and cold
perhaps they will be fined at the burial
site
investigators have a monumental task
ahead but ukraine is confident that some
of the stories of those buried here will
provide more evidence of war crimes